skyrim and mods go together like mac and
cheese peanut butter and jelly pineapple
and pizza it's just a magical
combination and after 10 years since the
game's release there are more mods for
skyrim than a nord can shake a sword at
we even had a show dedicated to them
with over 100 episodes and i'll be sure
to link that in the description if you
want to watch it later in this video i'm
gonna run down just a few of skyrim's
best mods from the past decade for more
videos on skyrim and eventually elder
scrolls 6 make sure you're subscribed to
gamespot
skyrim's menus are often considered
clunky and too console friendly sky ui
is a more pc friendly version of the
game's user interface that makes menu
navigation faster with mouse and
keyboard it stays true to the game's
original style while also doing away
with some of the visual clutter and
adding sorting full text search and
expanded columns of data sky ui also
features a mod configuration menu that
is used by hundreds of other mods as
well making this an essential install
so do you love restarting skyrim but
you're sick of hearing this
hey you
are finally awake
the intro to skyrim can be pretty
lengthy especially if you've done it a
dozen times but with this mod you can
completely bypass those opening moments
in helgen instead you can begin in a
dungeon where you choose your race and
what life you want your character to
lead it's the ultimate re-rolling tool
but if you want to learn more about how
that lengthy intro was almost completely
derailed by a bee check out this video
from kurt i'll link it in the
description
and if you really love playing through
that intro of skyrim and just want to
spice things up a bit you can always opt
for this mod which replaces dragons with
thomas the tank engine characters really
useful dragons doesn't just replace the
looks of the scaly beast it also swaps
the dragon's sounds with appropriate
sounds as well
and while thomas tooting at you as a
recipe for a good time maybe you want
your own character to be just as out of
place crimes against nature is a mod
that contains 12 new custom races
including dover bear ikea born pony and
sanic among others
now these may be two separate mods but
they basically go hand in hand and if
you love one you'll love the other as
the names imply these mods add new armor
and weapons to the world of skyrim
without breaking the lore balance or
overall feel of the game in order to
provide a more immersive experience for
players each item is craftable
upgradable enchantable and integrated
into the game's quest rewards vendors
dungeons and more
this is another mod that aims to
increase player immersion by granting
the ability to hide the game's heads up
display when it's no longer needed this
includes elements such as the compass
and crosshair which can also change
transparency separately floating quest
markers are only visible when the
compass is and the crosshair is only
visible when using a ranged weapon or
spell or when moving over an activatable
item immersive hud also speeds up how
fast the magic health and stamina bars
fade away once they've reached 100
in skyrim you are the legendary
dragonborn and as such you gotta look
good and there's no better way to slay
get it slay than to step out with a
fresh haircut with apache sky hair you
can rock new human elf and orc styles
converted from sims 2 and 3 oblivion and
witcher hair in total this mod adds over
200 new male and female styles to skyrim
another great customization mod is race
menu this adds more choices in hair
color and skin tone as well as adding a
height scaler and war paint you can
paint your body hands and even your feet
for a real head to toe tattoo look
skyrim with better visuals who wouldn't
want that listed as the most downloaded
high-resolution texture pack for skyrim
on nexus mods skyrim hd adds a high-res
coat of paint to the game the mod
includes a normal version with some
textures up to 8k and a light version up
to 1k each version features over 600
upgradable textures and is split into
towns dungeons landscapes and more
wandering around skyrim comes with the
expectation of encountering lots and
lots of vegetation so why not make all
that greenery look even greener this mod
does exactly as the name says and
overhauls the game's flora for a more
lush and varied landscape
have you ever played skyrim and thought
man that rope looks pretty ugly if so
then static mesh improvement is here to
help you out but it's not just for ropes
this improves over
750 meshes around skyrim including
barrels chains fences campfire rocks and
more
labeled as the number one weather and
lighting overhaul for skyrim this mod
features retextured clouds over 500
unique weather systems and over 2 000
unique days nights sunrises and sunsets
the goal of climates of tamriel is to
make skyrim's visual effects more
realistic
[Music]
not crazy about skyrim's map well this
mod improves the quality of the world
map and even features hand-drawn roads
the map's roots and landmarks have more
detail and give the player more
information at a single glance it also
includes the map from the dragonborn dlc
perfect for all you magic lovers this
popular skyrim mod includes 155
balanced and lore friendly spells not
included in vanilla skyrim on top of
that each new spell comes complete with
high quality custom visuals there are 31
per school and each spell can be bought
or looted just like the ones included
already
[Music]
and if you want a little realism with
your skyrim then realistic dolls and
force might be for you this mod reduces
the extra force applied to ragdolls and
can also replace those rag dolls
allowing for more realistic twist and
bend other features include arrows and
magic no longer sending foes flying away
weight increase for better fall velocity
and less stiffness to limbs
another popular mod in the animation
department is new idols this adds custom
animations to vanilla skyrim that
include idols and poses kill moves dance
moves creature animations and more the
coolest thing i've seen done with this
is coupling it with a flying mod
now come on you can't tell me that's not
cool
this new lands mod is one of the most
popular for skyrim and even helped its
creator get a job at bungie
it adds a whole new area to explore 30
plus hours of fully voiced gameplay 26
quests 9 main and 17 side 40 minutes of
new music and more if you've done
everything there is to do in skyrim then
this mod is a solid next step
[Music]
so many mods so little time this is just
17 out of thousands upon thousands so
keep in mind just because a mod wasn't
on this list doesn't mean it's not
awesome so hit the comment section and
let me know some others that you really
love and if you loved this video make
sure you hit the like button and
subscribe to gamespot for more
[Music]
is